على كل حال مشاهدينا سالنا الناس في مصر
ما رايك في رفض البعض اعتماد تحليل الدي
ان اي لاثبات النسب دعونا نتابع
[موسيقى]
لازما تكون طالعه رسميه من الازهر يعني ما
بتبقاش طالعه من فرض او من شخص يعني لان
في الاخر احنا ما بناخدش اشخاص يعني كل
واحد بيبقى له رايه يتاخد به او
يرد عليه يعني المشايخ يتكلم عن الدين لكن
التحليل الديني ده الطب الدكاتره هم اللي
يتكلموا في ده ينفع او ما ينفعش كده هو
تجرب واتعمل في قضايا كتير قبل كده واثبات
النسب اللي يقول كده طبعا اصحاب المهن
الطبيه واللي يقول كده طبعا الجهات
الرسميه المتعلقه باصدار الفتاوى في مصر
يبقى خلاص الجثه اللي بتخش وبتتحلل يبقى
ده كلام اونطه يبقى مش تحلين مظبوط دوت
لازم يكون فيه
علميه وخلفيه دينيه دول هم الاتنين
بيبوظوا بعض انا شايف
ناس كتير قوي رغم ان في ناس كتير بيحاول
ان هو يقوله يعكس كده ان هو بيكلمهم في
اساس ان لو حصل اختلاط يعني مثلا احنا
عندنا مثلا مفيش تنظيم مثلا اختلاط احيانا
ما بين العلب او انت مش تدوني على الاسم
العلبه والناس المتبايعين
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات